[Music]
someone must have been telling lies
about joseph k he knew he had done
nothing wrong but one morning he was
arrested
thus begins the trial one of author
franz kafka's most well-known novels
kay the protagonist is arrested out of
nowhere and made to go through a
bewildering process where neither the
cause of his arrest nor the nature of
the judicial proceedings are made clear
to him
this sort of scenario is considered so
characteristic of kafka's work that
scholars came up with a new word for it
kafka-esque has entered the vernacular
to describe unnecessarily complicated
and frustrating experiences
like being forced to navigate labyrinths
of bureaucracy
but does standing in a long line to fill
out confusing paperwork really capture
the richness of kafka's vision beyond
the words casual use what makes
something kafka-esque
franz kafka's stories do indeed deal
with many mundane and absurd aspects of
modern bureaucracy drawn in part from
his experience of working as an
insurance clerk in early 20th century
prague
many of his protagonists are office
workers compelled to struggle through a
web of obstacles in order to achieve
their goals
and often the whole ordeal turns out to
be so disorienting and illogical that
success becomes pointless in the first
place
for example in the short story poseidon
the ancient greek god is an executive so
swamped with paperwork that he's never
had time to explore his underwater
domain
the joke here is that not even a god can
handle the amount of paperwork demanded
by the modern workplace
but the reason why is telling he's
unwilling to delegate any of the work
because he deems everyone else unworthy
of the task
kafka's poseidon is a prisoner of his
own ego
this simple story contains all of the
elements that make for a truly
kafka-esque scenario
it's not the absurdity of bureaucracy
alone but the irony of the character's
circular reasoning in reaction to it
that is emblematic of kafka's writing
his tragicomic stories act as a form of
mythology for the modern industrial age
employing dream logic to explore the
relationships between systems of
arbitrary power and the individuals
caught up in them
take for example kafka's most famous
story metamorphosis when gregor samhsa
awakens one morning to find himself
transformed into a giant insect his
greatest worry is that he gets to work
on time of course this proves impossible
it was not only the authoritarian realm
of the workplace that inspired kafka
some of his protagonists struggles come
from within the short story a hunger
artist describes a circus performer
whose act consists of extended fasts
he's upset that the circus master limits
these to 40 days believing this prevents
him from achieving greatness in his art
but when his act loses popularity he is
left free to starve himself to death
the twist comes when he lays dying in
anonymity regretfully admitting that his
art has always been a fraud he fasted
not through strength of will but simply
because he never found a food he liked
even in the trial which seems to focus
directly on bureaucracy the vague laws
and bewildering procedures point to
something far more sinister
the terrible momentum of the legal
system proves unstoppable even by
supposedly powerful officials
this is a system that doesn't serve
justice but whose sole function is to
perpetuate itself
what political theorist hannah errant
writing years after kafka's death would
call tyranny without a tyrant
yet accompanying the bleakness of
kafka's stories there's a great deal of
humor rooted in the nonsensical logic of
the situations described
so on the one hand it's easy to
recognize the kafka-esque in today's
world
we rely on increasingly convoluted
systems of administration that have real
consequences on every aspect of our
lives
and we find our every word judged by
people we can't see according to rules
we don't know
on the other hand by fine-tuning our
attention to the absurd kafka also
reflects our shortcomings back at
ourselves
in doing so he reminds us that the world
we live in is one we create
and have the power to change for the
better
[Music]
you